- So this isn't legal advice,
but if you're gonna steal
$4 billion worth of Bitcoin,
maybe keep a low profile
and don't do this.
♪ Everyone worries too
much about what's proper ♪
♪ But not Razz ♪
♪ No shame, that don't stop her ♪
♪ Blindly following rules is for fools ♪
- Yes, stealing billions of
dollars in Bitcoin is a crime,
but those rap videos are
crimes against humanity.
(upbeat music)
Yes, with the development of the internet
and cryptocurrency, so
too came the opportunity
for spectacular criming.
How spectacular?
Well, criming in the dollar amount of-
(dramatic music)
- Billions.
- Enter one Heather Morgan, 31,
and her Russian-born husband,
Ilya Dutch Lichtenstein, 34,
who have been charged by
the Department of Justice
with trying to launder an
astounding $4.5 billion
in stolen Bitcoins.
This case is so captivating,
not just because of the
staggering dollar amounts
or what the DOJ described as the alleged
labyrinth of cryptocurrency transactions
to launder the stolen funds,
but what makes this case
so headline grabbing,
well, the defendants are, to
put it mildly, a bit out there.
Lichtenstein calls himself
a technology entrepreneur,
coder, and investor,
while his wife Morgan...
Well, I'll let Morgan introduce
herself in her own words.
♪ I'm many things ♪
♪ A rapper, an economist, a
journalist, a writer, a CEO ♪
♪ And a dirty, dirty, dirty, dirty ho ♪
- In addition to being an
irreverent comedic rapper
using the stage name Razzlekhan,
yes, I am not making that up,
Morgan is also self-described
as, "A serial entrepreneur."
Because of course she is.
And a former prolific
contributor to "Forbes" Magazine,
she's even dubbed herself
the Crocodile of Wall Street,
for some reason.
So today let's think like
a cyber security lawyer
who may or may not make
investment decisions
based on dog memes.
So we'll dive into the
stunning indictment,
examine the characters involved,
and analyze the implications on the law
and cryptocurrency in general,
and determine if this isn't only
the largest money laundering
scheme in history,
but also the cringiest.
All right, so let's
start with the indictment
and the weirdos involved.
Back in 2016, hackers
stole 119,754 Bitcoins
from the Bitfinex cryptocurrency
exchange in Hong Kong.
Since that hack, the value of
the Bitcoins has skyrocketed
from $72 million to an
astounding $4.5 billion in 2022.
For six years, those monies
successfully evaded the grasp
of law enforcement, until now.
On February 8th, 2022, the
Justice Department announced
the arrest of Ilya
Lichtenstein and Heather Morgan
from their New York high rise apartment.
In its statement on the arrest,
the DOJ reported having
successfully recovered
80% of the Bitcoin stolen from
Bitfinex, or $3.6 billion,
making it the largest
financial seizure in history.
Department officials also stated
that they plan to establish
a court process for victims
seeking to reclaim their stolen Bitcoin.
Lichtenstein and Morgan faced
up to 20 years in prison
for money laundering charges.
In addition, the pair could
receive an additional sentence
of up to five years for
the charge of conspiracy
to defraud the United States.
Now, for those of you who
haven't had money laundering
explained to them by Saul Goodman-
- Your filthy drug money
has been transformed
into nice clean taxable income
brought to you by a savvy
investment in a thriving business.
- It refers to the act of
making large amounts of money
obtained by criminal activity
appear to come from legal sources.
And conspiracy to
defraud the United States
generally criminalizes
the use of deception
to cheat the government
out of property or money,
or to otherwise impair,
obstruct, or defeat
the lawful function of the government.
Interestingly, the
indictment does not allege
that the pair are the ones
who actually stole the money.
It only alleges that an unknown hacker
gave them the stolen Bitcoin,
and that the couple attempted to launder
the billions of dollars in
crypto to evade law enforcement.
Following their initial court appearance,
the magistrate judge ruled
that Lichtenstein could be
released into home detention
on a $5 million bond
cosigned by his parents.
The bond amount for Morgan
was set at $3 million,
but both parties were
ordered to remain in custody
until the bail conditions were met.
Prosecutors opposed granting
the defendants bail,
claiming that they were
significant flight risks.
Prosecutors argued that just a portion
of the billions of dollars in crypto
that they've stole or tried to
launder could buy a new house
or, "Buy each of their
parents a private island."
Prosecutors further
warned that Lichtenstein,
who holds dual citizenship
in the U.S. and Russia,
was a particular flight risk
as he could flee to
Russia and seek immunity
if he were no longer held in
the United States' custody.
Federal District Judge Beryl
Howell agreed with prosecutors
and modified the magistrate's
bail order accordingly.
On February 14th, the judge
revoked Lichtenstein's bail
and ordered him to remain
in jail pending trial.
Judge Howell said that
the government had deemed
that Morgan was not as involved
in planning the alleged
crimes as her husband,
and that Lichtenstein
was largely in control
of the funds himself.
Judge Howell also considered
Morgan's health issues
as a factor as she recently had surgery
to remove a lump in her breast.
With follow-up doctor's
appointments expected,
the court released
Morgan into house arrest
with a GPS ankle monitor.
Now I would be remiss not
to take this opportunity
to go into the storied background
of Dutch and Razzlekhan.
So before delving into the
specifics of the indictment,
which I should note are only allegations
until prove true in a court of law
as the defendants are presumed
innocent until proven guilty,
I wanna give a little
background on the couple
that "The New York Times" has dubbed
Bitcoin's Bonnie and Clyde.
Now, Lichtenstein, who
goes by the nickname Dutch,
describes himself on his LinkedIn page
as an angel investor
in technology companies
and an advisor to various startups.
A Twitter account purportedly in his name
posted frequently on
cryptocurrency trends,
the technology sector,
and the evolution of NFTs.
While Dutch seemed to stick
to being your prototypical crypto bro,
his wife Morgan jumped between being
a self-described serial entrepreneur
and in her words a, "Raunchy
rapper making surrealist art."
Morgan was also a frequent
contributor to "Forbes" Magazine,
publishing more than 55 pieces
between July 2017 and September 2021.
Morgan also published articles
on a variety of topics
ranging from soul food
served at the 2021 Met Gala,
why women are better negotiators than men,
and, ironically, expert tips
on protecting your business
from cyber criminals.
- It's not ironic.
It's just coincidental.
- And, I mean, in fairness,
she probably knows more
about hacking Bitcoin
accounts than most people,
so maybe she is an expert in this area.
Now Morgan is also a
prolific presence on TikTok,
rapping under the name Razzlekhan.
According to her website,
she's, "Like Genghis Khan,
"but with more pizazz."
She also characterizes
herself as basically a mix
of Hunter S. Thompson and Diane Arbus,
with a sprinkle of Tom Green.
And yeah, I mean I guess she's not
completely wrong about that.
And look, it's easy to make
fun, but all art is subjective
and it's really not
anyone's place to judge art
as good or bad.
♪ What ♪
♪ Razzle Dazzle living in a glass castle ♪
♪ Don't (beep) with no hassle ♪
- Okay, I take it back.
If the pair is found guilty,
I really hope that the
judge issues an injunction
preventing Ms. Morgan
from ever rapping again,
and also request that Ms.
Morgan pay restitution
to my eyes and ears for
all the videos I've watched
in preparing for this video.
Uh, yeah.
Now let's get onto the complaint itself
and onto the whole issue of
laundering billions of dollars
in stolen cryptocurrency.
Now in the statement
announcing the arrest,
here's how the DOJ summarized
the defendants' alleged
money laundering scheme.
The criminal complaint alleges
that Lichtenstein and Morgan
employed numerous sophisticated
laundering techniques,
including using fictitious identities
to set up online accounts,
utilizing computer programs
to automate the transactions,
a laundering technique that allows
for many transactions to take place
in a short period of time,
depositing the stolen funds into accounts
at a variety of virtual currency exchanges
and darknet markets.
Basically, they would often
try to convert Bitcoin
into other forms of virtual currency
and other real tangible assets,
including anonymity
enhanced virtual currency
in a practice known as chain hopping,
and using U.S.-based business accounts
to legitimize their banking activity.
According to Jim Lee of the
IRS Criminal Investigation,
they conducted a methodical
and calculated scheme
to allegedly launder and
disguise their vast fortune.
And here's how the government
says that they did it.
In or around August of 2016,
a hacker breached the
Bitfinex security system
and infiltrated its infrastructure.
Once in the network,
the unidentified hacker
was able to initiate over 2,000
unauthorized Bitcoin transactions,
resulting in 119,754
Bitcoins being transferred
from Bitfinex wallets to an
unidentified outside wallet
controlled by the defendants.
Now, if you read the actual complaint
you'd be shocked to see how little
of the billions of dollars in Bitcoin
was actually laundered and spent.
In fact, about 80% of the
nearly 120,000 stolen Bitcoin,
the 3.6 billion that the
government recovered,
was found in exactly
the same crypto wallet
into which they were originally deposited.
As for the remaining 20%, well,
starting in January of 2017,
defendants allegedly began moving
some of the stolen Bitcoins
out of the original wallet
through a series of small
and complex transactions
across multiple accounts and platforms.
Now, one of those accounts
that the Bitcoin was funneled into
was the AlphaBay Marketplace,
a prominent darknet market
that was shut down in 2017 by the FBI
working in conjunction with
international law enforcement.
Now, the defendants used a high number
of very small transactions
to conceal the path
of the stolen Bitcoin and avoid
law enforcement for years.
So the $3.6 billion question is,
how did the defendants get caught?
Well, it was a mix of good
old fashioned police work,
due diligence from the private sector,
and the public nature of
the blockchain itself.
Oh, and the most helpful
element in any investigation,
really stupidly sloppy mistakes
from the alleged criminals.
Because on January 31st, 2022,
law enforcement gained lawful access
to Dutch's cloud storage
pursuant to a search warrant.
Law enforcement decrypted a single file
in Dutch's cloud storage
that contained a list
of 2,000 virtual currency addresses,
along with the corresponding private keys
to open all of those wallets.
That's not surprising because
one of the most tedious things
about cryptocurrency is keeping track
of all your accounts and private keys.
And that's hard for even people
that have stolen billions
of dollars in crypto coins.
Analyzing the public blockchain records,
the feds confirmed that those addresses
came from the 2016 hack,
because the blockchain
is completely public.
Now in the days that followed,
the feds obtained seizure warrants
and used those private keys
contained in Dutch's file
to seize over $3.6 billion in Bitcoin
and place them into the
government's possession.
Also discovered in Dutch's cloud,
a folder entitled "Personas"
that included biographical info
and documents on numerous individuals,
a file entitled "Passport Ideas"
with links to darknet sites
selling fake passports,
and a folder with potential
financial institutions
to launder the money, which
described AlphaBank as a,
"Sketchy Russian oligarch bank."
Which is definitely not wrong.
And not only that, but Dutch's
apartment also contained
a bag labeled "Burner phones."
You know, it really makes law
enforcement's job a lot easier
when suspects properly
categorize their crimes
and pre-labeled the
evidence of their arrest.
It's really considerate.
Now the private sector, aided
by government regulation,
was also instrumental in halting
some of the defendants'
illegal activities.
Currency exchanges are regulated
by the Treasury Department,
which requires such institutions
to establish anti-money
laundering, AML, programs
and KYC, Know Your Customer, protocols
to make it harder for anonymous
users to transfer money.
In one example of the system working,
the defendants allegedly set
up seven AlphaBay accounts
and six from an established exchange
to hold $186,000 in
Bitcoin under false names.
However, following these
verification protocols,
exchanges were unable to
verify defendants' identities
or prove that they owned the accounts.
So the accounts were frozen.
And despite the setbacks,
defendants did successfully
launder some of those Bitcoins
out of third party exchanges.
And according to the indictment,
defendants use their ill-gotten gains
to pay for relatively benign items,
such as Uber rides, Hotel.com
stays, a PlayStation, NFTs,
a $500 Walmart gift card, and even gold.
But the defendants' alleged sloppiness,
which allegedly bordered on stupidity,
continued to hinder their
efforts at money laundering
while also at the same time
helping law enforcement
to track them down.
The gold that Dutch purchased
with stolen Bitcoin?
Well, he purchased it
from an online currency exchange account
which he verified with
his real driver's license,
which he sent with a
selfie-style photograph,
and he registered that to
his real email address,
and then Dutch had the gold
shipped to his real home address
at the time in San Francisco.
Then again, I guess this is
exactly what one might expect
from someone who kept
the keys to $3.6 billion
in cryptocurrency in one cloud file.
Or who married Morgan.
Now, Morgan's less-than-genius behavior
also raised some red flags.
In response to one currency exchange
asking follow-up questions
about the origins
of the tens of thousands of
dollars in digital assets
that were to be deposited
into Morgan's newly
created business account,
Morgan gave the following
not at all suspicious answer.
"My boyfriend, now husband,
gifted me cryptocurrency
"over several years, 2014,
2015, which have appreciated.
"I have been keeping
them in cold storage."
That obviously cagey answer
is the money laundering equivalent of,
"My boyfriend, why he goes to
a different school in Canada.
"You wouldn't know him."
Another red flag?
Well, "The Wall Street Journal" reports
that a friend of Ms.
Morgan's noted how she
and her husband's lifestyle did not match
their purported wealth.
While planning to buy a $2
million condo in New York,
the defendants had a modest wedding
and the couple used airline miles to fly.
You know, just like the rest of us.
Now, maybe the best part
about this entire case
is that whether you a crypto
skeptic or a crypto booster,
there's plenty of material for both camps.
Crypto critics have often noted
that less than desirable
groups, like white supremacists,
have embraced crypto as a means
of evading law enforcement
and avoiding legal judgements.
Furthermore, in 2021, it
marked an all-time high
of $14 billion in cryptocurrency theft
with the innocent suffering
brunt of the consequences.
And of course the Bitfinex hack
and subsequent money
laundering only reinforces
critics' argument that
cryptocurrency is not just ripe
for criminal conduct, but
is also not nearly as secure
and unhackable as its boosters claim.
But at the same time,
crypto advocates show
that the blockchain's secure technology
is working exactly as intended.
In the words of crypto boosters,
"It's further proof that
the nature blockchain,
"and it being always
public, allows investigators
"to follow the money in ways
that would be impossible
"in complex webs of shell
companies and cash smuggling
"that exist with normal financial tools."
Crypto advocates argue
that the public nature
of blockchain technology not
only serves as self-regulating,
an anti-fraud measure, but that
the global blockchain ledger
allows police to track down
the stolen cryptocurrency
in ways that would not be
possible with fiat money.
"Bloomberg" columnist
Matt Levine highlights
this inherent contradiction
perfectly, as usual,
saying, "You might think that
a federal criminal indictment
"for $4.5 billion of
Bitcoin money laundering
"would be vindication
"of the 'Bitcoin is for
money launderers' side.
"But I want to tell you, no, it is not.
"What allegedly happened
here is that hackers stole
"4.5 billion of Bitcoin
from a crypto exchange,
"and stealing from exchanges absolutely
"is a major function of crypto,
"and then they had a
horrible time laundering it.
"They managed to extract only
a relatively small portion
"of the money for actual spending,
"and each time they got money out
"the feds were able to
trace it from the hack
"all the way to legitimate
accounts with their names on it."
Matt Levine goes on to analogize,
"If you rob a bank and
steal a sack of money
"and the bills are sequentially numbered
"and a dye pack explodes in the sack
"and you drive directly to another bank
"and hand them a dye-stain sack and say,
"'I'd like to make a deposit, please,'
"you will totally get arrested
"and you will probably get
charged with money laundering.
"But in no meaningful sense
did you launder the money.
"It still has the dye on it.
"That's what happened here."
And as another crypto expert said,
"The problem with
laundering cryptocurrency
"is that if you make a
mistake five years ago,
"that's still on the blockchain
for everyone to see."
But I guess one thing
that we can all agree
is that whatever your
take on cryptocurrency,
remember that talking about it constantly
does not make you cool.
Now, admittedly, we've all had our fun,
engaged in a whole bunch of schadenfreude
over Razzlekhan and Dutch.
But you know what goes
well with schadenfreude?
A nice glass of wine,
and you can get the perfect bottle
with today's sponsor, Bright Cellars.
Bright Cellars is a delightful service
that helps you find new, fun
wines from all over the world.
It doesn't matter if you know
absolutely nothing about wine.
Just go to Brightcellers.com
and take their seven-question quiz.
Now I like big bold reds,
and if we're being pedantic,
and obviously we are 'cause
this is "LegalEagle,"
I like Left Bank bordeaux and
Cabernets from Paso Robles.
But you don't to know any of that.
You just need to tell them
what kind of flavors you like,
whether you like reds or whites or both,
and tell them how adventurous you are
and they'll do the rest for you.
Bright Cellars will match you
with several great bottles
and deliver them straight to your house.
You get great stuff
from all over the world,
and I got stuff I never
would've found on my own,
like this Folk and Fable Cabernet
from Santa Rosa, California
and this French Mise En
Abyme from near Bordeaux.
And I love that there are
wine education cards included,
so you learn about what you're drinking
to better articulate what you like.
Or just fool your wine snob friends.
And right now Bright
Cellars is offering viewers
50% off their first box.
That's six bottles of wine for only $53.
That's crazy value,
and you're guaranteed
to love what you get.
Just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or down below in the
description to take the quiz.
You get half off your first box,
and you'll be supporting this channel.
Or you can click on
this playlist over here
for the rest of my educational-ish videos.
So click here or I'll see you in court.